huella una palabra tan pequeña pero como
un gran significado
quiero compartir con ustedes el proceso
que me llevó a entender esta palabra
hace algún tiempo atrás me preguntaron
jose antonio como empezaste en el arte
mi respuesta mi primer pincel a los
siete años de edad
y en la música mi primera guitarra
cuando tenía aproximadamente 12 años
pues tanta la emoción que hasta me pinté
el cabello
pero buscando algunos registros encontré
lo siguiente
indudablemente no tuve mucha suerte con
el micrófono
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero dicen que el que persevera alcanza
y desde que tuve el micrófono en mis
manos me prometí nunca más soltarlo y es
una promesa que mantengo
hasta el día de hoy
[Música]
indudablemente al ver con nostalgia y
emoción estos vídeos corro ver que el
arte estaba presente en mi vida desde
muy temprana edad
y que había un patrón y era que amaba lo
que hacía en algún momento de mi carrera
artística decide indagar un poco más
sobre mis artistas favoritos y ello me
llevó a encontrar este mismo patrón ya
no solamente en la música sino también
literarios arquitectos científicos
filósofos políticos religiosos
espirituales que de cierta manera
dejaron un legado sea pequeño o grande
pero que han luchado por dejar algo en
este mundo pero por qué es tan
importante amar lo que uno hace
vamos a ver tú
a más lo que hace es realmente
amamos todos nosotros lo que hacemos
cada día
cuántas podrían alzar la mano y decir yo
amo lo que hago todos los días
falta un poquito de motivación no
yo diría que uno de los principales
factores que influye y que nos dice por
qué es tan importante amar lo que
hacemos es porque el que ama lo que hace
se atreve a arriesgarse uno puede tomar
el riesgo de cosas importantes que
pueden marcar grandes diferencias en lo
personal por ejemplo por citar un
pequeño riesgo cuando decidí por primera
vez cantar frente a mis compañeros de
clase o cuando fui por primera vez a una
entrevista de radio o incluso cuando fui
a audicionar a un concurso internacional
pero luego de encontrar que el factor
del riesgo era importante también me di
cuenta de que faltaba un elemento en esa
fórmula de esas personas y era algo
importante que contar y para ello
descubrí que habían dos puntos
fundamentales el primero que es
experimentar es muy importante hoy en
día tratar de llenarnos de un bagaje de
pensamientos de sentimientos que nos
permite un poco depurar nuestra
personalidad nos permite formarnos y
hacer una especie de boceto de quiénes
somos de qué nos gusta de que rechazamos
y eso está muy bien y el segundo punto
es ser receptivos
muchas veces escucharemos decir hijo por
qué no sales a otro país a estudiar o
por qué no aprender nuevos idiomas
porque nos salimos de la burbuja conoces
nuevas culturas nuevas amistades en fin
es importante hacer esto pero hay que
tener mucho cuidado de no perdernos en
esa búsqueda y justamente ahí está el
problema
hoy en día conocemos cuál es la canción
de moda conocemos qué es lo que pasa en
la política en la farándula lo que pasa
en cualquier parte del mundo porque la
tecnología nos ha brindado esas
posibilidades
pero lamentablemente no sabemos hace
mucho tiempo de qué es la vida de
nuestros hermanos hace mucho que ni
siquiera hemos entablado una
conversación con un vecino nuestro o ni
siquiera se nos han tocado averiguar un
poco cómo se conocieron nuestros abuelos
cuando se escribían esas cartas a puño y
letra' y que cuando nos cuentan esas
historias es como transportarse en el
tiempo
y justamente dirán bueno pero es fácil
realmente decir quiénes somos no
pero estas preguntas
sin duda alguna cuando nos dejamos
abordar por esta corriente de contenido
desbordante que tenemos día a día muchas
veces nos olvidamos de quiénes somos
como diría thalía pero no me acuerdo no
me acuerdo ya se la saben que están
aplaudiendo entonces
tal vez podría responder fácilmente
bueno mi nombre es josé antonio mora
tengo 31 años soy sing escorpio soy
creyente soy de loja de ecuador pero la
identidad va mucho más allá de eso va
más allá de una formación o de una
profesión la identidad es difícil de
escribirla con palabras pero es algo que
podemos sentir como nuestro y es cuando
fusionamos todas las cosas que vivimos
en el día a día pero las conjugamos con
parte de nuestras raíces de nuestras
tradiciones
y uno no empieza a entender que es la
identidad hasta que no extraña
algunas ocasiones tuve la oportunidad de
representar a mi país a nivel
internacional ya pesar de que tenía la
bandera de ecuador en diferente y que
obviamente lo hacía con todo mi amor
sentía que aún me faltaba empaparme de
mi país fue entonces cuando empecé a
extrañar los paisajes de mi tierra la
música la gente
ese olor que no sabemos cómo describir
lo que está en la casa de nuestros
padres o de nuestros abuelos
eso es identidad
ahora bien cuando empecé a descifrar
esta estos cuestionamientos no podía
descuidar a mi parte espiritual y es que
cuando uno está cargado de problemas
ahí es cuando uno puede refugiarse en la
fe
y hablo de una fe que va más allá de
religiones estaremos de acuerdo que no
todos compartimos tal vez la misma
religión pero la gran mayoría de ellas
nos comunican valores similares el
respeto el amor la unidad y la gratitud
también
somos conscientes de lo afortunados que
somos
realmente somos conscientes de la
fortuna dos que somos
es fácil prender la televisión leer el
diario y ver en las noticias que hay
muchas personas que están atravesando
problemas mucho más complicados que los
nuestros día a día y que aún así siguen
luchando para salir adelante
incluso algunas personas arriesgan su
vida en cuestión de segundos
mientras que otras personas
luchan segundo a segundo por estar vivos
esta sensibilidad nos permite
desarrollar también un poco de
conciencia y entender que al ser parte
de este mundo porque somos parte de este
planeta a todos
compartimos un espacio compartimos
pensamientos sentimientos experiencias
nos comunicamos yo creo que ya por eso
les debemos una retribución a la
sociedad y debemos tener un compromiso y
una responsabilidad
hoy en día consumimos mucho más de lo
que proponemos que estamos proponiendo
al mundo entre tantas fotografías vídeo
material que vemos en todas partes qué
mensaje estamos transmitiendo tengo los
elementos necesarios para contar una
historia diferente
eso lo dirá el tiempo sin embargo
proponer no es fácil no no no si estamos
pensando a conseguir cosas de la noche a
la mañana no el camino no es fácil
muchas veces nos van a decir no sabes
que tengo una mejor idea o a lo mejor
nos ignoran o nos subestiman o incluso
nos digan no
tendremos que salir de nuestra zona de
confort tendremos que sacrificar cosas
salir de nuestras ciudades e incluso
salir de nuestros países
proponer no es fácil se requiere de
trabajo de disciplina de perseverancia
de un cierto grado de locura y también
de creatividad en cualquier rama o
profesión en la que estemos involucrados
todos estos cuestionamientos me llevaron
a una conclusión y es que lo que uno
siembra con fe
con amor lo que uno riega con trabajo
con disciplina con perseverancia algún
día sin dudas va a florecer y cuando
cosechamos eso
tenemos que hacerlo con humildad y con
gratitud
esta fórmula que quiero compartir con
ustedes no sirve sólo para un momento
específico de la vida puede ser una
manera de vivir de hoy en adelante
hace algunos años atrás decidí emprender
en un sueño loco que se llamaba baby t
la productora audiovisual con la idea de
hacer grandes materiales y producciones
con pocos recursos y con pocos elementos
quién iba a pensar que años más tarde
estaría transformándose en una agencia
artística
incluyéndose y también trabajando en su
gran mayoría en proyectos artísticos y
culturales aquellas melodías de los 16
años en los que estamos ilusionados
llenos de elementos de inspiración de
suspiros
que esas primeras canciones hoy van a
ser ya mi tercera producción
discográfica que fusiona algunos géneros
latinoamericanos con sonidos un poco más
modernos como para decirles a las nuevas
generaciones saber está chévere lo de
ahora pero también hay algo que no se lo
puede reemplazar no
y que todas estas respuestas y estos
lineamientos que fui encontrando me
sirvieron para también crear mi primera
novela juvenil que trata de invitar a
jóvenes y adolescentes a encontrar sus
propósitos de vida por medio de una
historia musical
incluso
se construyó un instrumento bajo este
mismo nombre que junta todos los
elementos anteriores y que ahora sí
puedo corroborar su significado que
según el diccionario de la real academia
de la lengua española significa huella
impresión profunda o duradera
y
sí
si te toca
y te llega si te unes valor habrá dolor
y arrepentimiento
es la pasión de esta decisión
[Música]
marcha atrás
la instancia a vivir reinando
tu corazón
gm la intuición sólo déjate que para una
mueca pasada
saltando cantando no mires atrás tan
buena como tú puedes dejar tu que en el
tiempo nos da puerta tras puerta
a ella
la juega
bueno
vamos a ver
ahora que conocen mi historia
[Música]
se animan a dejar la huella
muchas gracias